The joe rogan experience.
We know a guy who,
uh,
was,
like I,
I talk,
I tell the story now on stage of the guy who used to drive us,
oh my God to the airport.
This was our driver,
like a regular guy cause we were,
we'd go to the airport.
So often we use this,
you know,
we found a,
like a cheaper car service.
It's easier than dealing with like driving and parking and like,
he was,
uh,
you know,
it was like a cheap ride,
basically older guy and like all white hair and was really professional.
And then like,
after like 10 rides,
one of those things where like,
you know,
when somebody is like Mr Rogue and Mr and you finally go,
you can call me Joe.
It was like,
that kind of thing where I was like,
it's Tom,
he's like this Tom.
I'm like,
yeah.
He's like,
cool.
Hey Man,
let me ask you something.
Like,
every changed.
As soon as I said,
like,
you don't have to be professional with me.
And he goes,
uh,
he goes,
can I ask you something?
And I was like,
yeah.
And he goes,
do you smoke weed?
And I was like,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
I guess,
yeah.
He's like,
do you want to smoke something now?
And I was like,
really?
It's like,
yeah,
and it's driving.
Yeah,
you and I was like,
I was like,
yeah.
All right.
And then you said,
yeah,
right?
Yeah.
Okay,
driver.
Yeah,
that's exactly what's in my head.
Comfortable with you in my life.
And then he goes,
he starts smoking and then he goes,
I can't drive unless I'm fucked up.
That's a quo,
it's like scene in a movie.
And then
I swear to God,
Shit.
And he goes,
he's like seventies and then he goes,
and then he's like,
this is more like this particularly,
it is early.
He drives fast.
He's like,
one of these,
I've been driving 50 years in La,
we've got to take this street.
And I was like,
you know,
I was basically like,
keep it together man.
And he's like,
he's like,
I've been up since,
you know,
three.
And I'm like,
he's off.
I ain't shit.
I start asking him,
I'm like,
have you done other drugs?
He's like,
oh buddy buddy.
Like I've done it all.
And I was like,
really?
He's like coke heroin.
He's like,
there's nothing like smoking rocks,
swear to God.
And I was like 17 and he is flying through El Barrio through the old
neighborhood.
Oh my God.
So this is a El Salvadorian neighborhoods,
like every,
like we're going through lights and he's like,
look at that little brown one right there.
That was a little brown.
One was married to a Peruvian and then he had like an El Salvadorian girlfriend.
He's like,
I love these little brown was one on the side.
Yeah.
Well,
and yet he has like five girlfriends and they're all like 20.
Like we drive to the ghetto and be like,
that's where I used to buy my crack.
This neighborhood's got the good stuff.
So we're in the,
we're driving around and I go,
uh,
I go,
oh,
what?
Can I ask you something now that we're friends,
I guess,
you know?
And he's like,
yeah.
And I was like,
what's it like to smoke crack?
And he goes,
oh man.
He was like,
what I like to do when I smoked crack is like,
I'll just sit in my apartment where it stop,
stop,
don't say anything.
Hold on.
Did he porn?
Who Watches porn?
No.
Okay,
go ahead.
I'm sorry.
He goes,
uh,
I like to,
I like to look through the people and I look around at what the fuck is that?
And I think I see all this shit.
I think about what's going to happen next.
And I see people walking by and he's kind of fucking freak out,
you know?
And I was like,
this sounds terrible man.
He was,
he was like,
as part of the rush,
that's the rush.
You know what the fuck's going to happen?
People come and get you.
That's his rush.
I had to stop you because yeah,
because everybody says everybody that ever,
ever talked to in smoked crack says they watch porn.
Oh,
oh,
come on.
Henry did say I invited this girl over and we fuck like animals you would have,
yeah,
he did say that.
Sorry.
Sorry,
I can't say his last name.
I don't know his last name.
Henry.
The eighth.
So the best is,
uh,
like in this sounds like it sounds,
I swear this is exactly how it goes.
I go,
so do you still do that shit?
And he goes,
Nah man,
Nah,
no,
no.
He goes,
well,
you know,
every once in a while,
but you know what they say if you do something every once in awhile,
it's not that bad for you.
And I go,
I think they mean that about like pizza,
like chocolate.
And he's like,
oh,
big deal buddy.
I swear to God every once in a while.
Do you remember when the mayor of Washington DC got caught smoke Marion Berry?
Yeah,
with an FBI agent in a fucking hotel room or an informant.
He was being a prostitute.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You remember that Shit.
He was smoking Crenn running the nation's capitol.
And then when they ask people about it,
the greatest thing was after he got caught,
this guy I met with this guy on TV,
they say,
what do you think about the mayor getting caught smoking crack goes man.
And by some a little cracking,
but now and then every now and he said,
everybody smoke a little crack every now and then.
This guy was on TV.
He's like,
come on man,
stop playing.
Stop playing
freaks and Geeks,
lovers and children.
What's going on ladies and gentlemen?